foreign
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to stylecraft I'm
Cameron and this week we're talking
about shape and shape and motion design
shape is squares triangles
circles shape is flat it's not
three-dimensional so when I think of
shape I think of things like circles
right this is something
um that I spent several days a few hours
here a few hours there creating what
you're going to see here that I want to
show you guys and
well without further Ado let me just
show you what the example is today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
and I'll play it one more time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
cool so the last word there says Circle
there is a lot of details in this
example that you may or may not be able
to see in the render you're seeing
online in the membership here because of
compression but I will include the
project file so you can take a look at
this
and really dissect it there's a lot of
three-dimensional planes here going back
in Z depth with these dots and there's a
lot of little details that go into this
thing
but I wanted to make my example to you
using just circles so I confine myself
to circles only even these dots are tiny
little circles
so circles to me could be you know
filled circles like this they could be
stroked circles like this and this and
then I added some elements of color that
made it that much more interesting so if
I was to just turn off the color here
which is under my effects it's actually
just a gradient
so if I turn that off a few of these
layers are colorized like this is
colorized
there's a few layers in
here towards the front their color eyes
just blue and that's just from trial and
experimentation but most of the layers
in here are just straight up white a few
of them are a little bit of a gray value
but when I added this gradient
to it and I did this effect to the
gradient I'm going to show you it made
it so much more interesting plus the
depth like we see here made this motion
design much more interesting uh the
movement
all these little things you know with
the basic shape element made this motion
design piece that much more interesting
so I want to show you how I created this
and then I'm going to give you an
assignment after this video for what you
guys need to do and uh we'll see what
you guys come up with so anyways without
any further Ado let's dive into this one
and recreate it I guarantee you it is
not going to look the same
but I will do my best uh one other quick
thing is there's a lot of layers here uh
33 plus the audio layers and there's a
few pre-comps here with layers inside of
them so I'm going to try and create
something with a little bit less layers
than this and we'll see but this is
always the fun part of rebuilding these
is seeing what else I come up with
that's similar sometimes not as cool
sometimes it's better so
let's dive in so the first I'm going to
do is I'm going to create a new
composition we're going to call this
circle
O2
it's going to be
1920
1080 24 frames a second and this one was
400 frames so we'll do
400 frames and we'll make the background
black
okay so there we go
get this down
so the most basic way to start this is
just to start with a new
shape layer
and in that shape layer I'm going to
select my ellipse tool and double click
and I'm going to make that ellipse
a circle which is 1080
by 1080. I'll lock that
and I think for this first one I want to
turn off the fill and turn on the stroke
so there we go before I get any further
I do want to jump back in here I want to
grab the music
so what I did here is I just took this
audio track that I believe was 20
seconds long to begin with and I just
did a simple edit and brought it down to
what is this 15 seconds long the audio
track that I'm using here and that I
like to use a lot of uh in a lot of the
different examples I show is from
epidemic sound
they're a music licensing company they
specialize more in YouTube social media
Instagram accounts things like that but
I have a license that I pay for monthly
and with that monthly license I'm able
to download as many tracks as I like
and I work for those tracks so some of
the tracks are you know mediocre a lot
of the tracks are really great and they
have a lot of different uh varieties and
styles
so I think for this I took a I think
it's like an old school hip-hop is what
I searched for
and plug that into my search engine came
up with this track
which we'll listen to real quick
[Applause]
thank you
and then it just Fades out so right here
on this
audio Gap not to get too much into
audio editing if I'm doing very simple
audio work I will just stick with After
Effects because I can you know get
around I just did simple Fades here so I
faded this top track in created this top
track out and I just kind of drug this
keyframe around farther back in space to
get a good
uh mix between the two so what I would
do is I'd set a beginning Point here an
end point here and I would Loop it
and while it's looping I would just drag
these keyframes around until I got a
nice smooth transition between them
and I was good to go
so
that is that the next thing I would do
is I would actually just I wouldn't
typically
keep the time frame full like this I
would probably drag it down into here
and I would just start with a small
section so I would listen to this
[Applause]
foreign so the first thing I heard was
this little bell sound
there's like three of them it's like
so I really liked that sound and uh you
know in this lesson I'm going to teach
you some things on timing right it's
about shapes and timing
so I hear that sound let me zoom in here
and I knew from those those
that I wanted the circle to do something
with that sound right
[Applause]
so what I would do is I'd come in here
and I'd probably like Mark
I'd hit shift one on my keyboard to Mark
the first sound
[Music]
[Applause]
then I'd hit shift 2 to Mark the next
sound
[Music]
[Applause]
and this doesn't have to be perfect
right
oops three
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't know I can tell it's already off
but I would just set markers and I know
like okay something needs to happen here
right
so
so the first thing to me that would be
interesting is just to bring this on
right so you know sometimes you can
start with animations and
elements are already there elements
already doing thing doing things and
that's totally fine sometimes that works
sometimes that doesn't work for this
particular animation I want to start on
Black
so maybe I would just you know scale it
up
so I'll just set a keyframe
back here go to zero
[Music]
I hear that snare right here
so I want something to happen there
right so
I don't know that could be a lot of
things that happens maybe it says we're
in a shape layer here let me lock this
audio Maybe
might be interesting to start playing
around with the the stroke right so the
stroke width is 476 maybe the stroke
width just snaps in you know really
tight maybe that's you know I like to
try things so I will lock this keyframe
which is I right click toggle hold
keyframe
so now whenever I set another keyframe
because it's a it's a hold keyframe it's
going to snap to whatever I set that to
this could work for position for scale
anything a hold keyframe says hold that
value until you hit the next keyframe
and immediately snap to that next value
there's no in between there's no
um
interpolating between two keyframes so
maybe we just do something like
this and you know would be cool if I
made the scale
snap down as well so I'll toggle a whole
keyframe that scale
and just bring it maybe like that
[Music]
[Applause]
so that works for now
not super exciting but maybe like right
here
maybe this is when
I could use a repeater I didn't do this
in the first example but I think it
might be cool here
so let's add a repeater
let's turn off the transform 100 down to
zero
and let's just do some scale repeating
again I'm going to do hold keyframe
I'm just going to drag it back it
doesn't matter where this keyframe is
you could put at the beginning of the
timeline you could put it right before
it doesn't matter I just like to I like
to have things even a lot of times even
numbers even keyframes so if if I line
up these keyframes in here
it pleases my mind for whatever reason
so maybe I'll scale this down
oh I don't know maybe something like
that
and let's do another whole keyframe
right here with the copies right so I'm
just realizing I don't actually need a
whole keyframe on the scale I can just
keep to scale at let's say 76.
actually let's make it
a little bit smaller maybe I don't know
I'm just guessing here 64. what I need
to hold keyframe on is the copies
so my first keyframe will be
there's just one copy
we get here and maybe there's
two copies and then the next ding
[Applause]
is maybe three copies
[Music]
[Applause]
maybe this is four
[Applause]
so I'm hearing those dings come in
sooner so I'm just going to keep playing
the music and drag these Keys around to
get the timing down right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
five here
[Applause]
and a lot of times the music music is
even right everything's on like Beats
so if I find that one two three four
five six frames
is a good amount of distance between
these two and it works then I'd go six
frames to this keyframe and six to this
one so I'd go one two three four five
six that one lines up one two three four
five six
that one one two three four five six
let's try that
[Applause]
so now I think maybe seven keyframes
would work instead
one two three four five six seven
one two three four five six seven
one two three four five six seven
let's see what this does
[Applause]
so that works for me now it might be
interesting to actually mess with the
scale like we talked about so let's do
hold keyframes on the scale
and maybe it's the second one here that
will go
let's go down by 10 54.
10 more would be 44.
34.
[Music]
[Applause]
so I don't love the jerkiness of the
scale but I like the movement so I'll
delete these let's try this
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
yeah it works for me needs to be eased
so I'll right click on these keyframes
easy ease I'm also gonna
right click on these keyframes when it's
scaled up so right here at the beginning
I wanted to ease into this
[Applause]
and maybe as everything is scaling down
here
it might be too much of a scale let's go
up between 44.
and maybe the whole thing
is
scaling down as well
so here I'm just looking at adding a
keyframe for the actual scale of the
layer
I'll make it an easy ease
something like that
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
maybe try the opposite way maybe I scale
it up
so it gives this false sense of actually
moving through it which we're not doing
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
drug the keyframe for the scale further
out so I wanted it to drift past
that and I'm looking for a beat here
[Music]
so right there
and then I'm going to get into graph
editor here hopefully this doesn't lose
you guys but essentially when you select
a key like this
you know we did an Ease on that key
which is shown here but if I take this
I'm in the
um speed graph editor right now which a
lot of times that's normally what I work
in I will just take that key and if I
drag it down you'll see the influence
numbers changing
you can go all the way to 100 right so
that's an extreme ease in
[Applause]
I did not like that so I undo it maybe
I'll try and extreme ease out
[Applause]
foreign
I did not like that either
so undo that just a straight up easy
ease
[Applause]
for me
I want all of these
copies
to kind of go away at this point so
maybe I could
scale up the copies
there's already a keyframe there
so maybe I'll just go the opposite way
here
scale up
to a hundred percent
then I'm going to scale up the layer so
it's it's gone off my screen here
so it's gone I can make a way for
another shape layer here
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
so listening back to it I actually want
this last movement to happen somewhere
in here this is where the snare hits
you hear that so maybe I just delete
this last copy
and I drag everything up here
and the snap the snare is such a quick
uh sound that I want my movement to
match
that sound quickness right it doesn't
have to be exact but it needs to be a
quick move to to
make that sound uh to to relate the
motion to the sound so
[Music]
so maybe this will work let's just
[Applause]
I think it'd be a little bit faster
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm also going to move to half Rez we
can keep this going in real time
[Applause]
yeah I like that that seems to work
[Applause]
so the only problem I have right now is
right in here so it rests and then it
sits
and then nothing happens even though
it's just a few frames nothing happens I
feel like something should happen there
and then it just sits here and this is a
really long
Gap and something needs to happen the
music's going we should see something
happening so let me listen to this
foreign
so maybe maybe a little shape layer pops
out of here right so I don't know the
easiest way to do that is maybe just to
duplicate this layer
so we'll just keep things tidy we'll
call this first
Circle
right duplicate it and then I'll hit you
on the keyboard and I'm just going to
delete all these keyframes
and let's see let's open up this layer
let's actually make this layer which
we'll call
second oops
if I can spell right second Circle
and maybe we'll turn off the stroke on
this one
and we'll hit fill and we'll turn on
fill
and we're gonna go ahead and make it
white
and I want this guy to be little all
right so let's just scale this guy down
and I don't even know what this guy is
going to do maybe this guy appears
right here so it looks like the circle
is full
but uh maybe it scales down really quick
so I will hit option bracket to
change the start point of this layer to
here
as you can see there
so the keyframe from scale and maybe
let's see let's open up these keys
I don't know maybe it starts here no no
no let's just
it'll pop in here and then right here is
where the movement will start No Maybe
not maybe not
let's have this guy scale down just I
don't know maybe down to zero maybe it's
real simple and I'll do option bracket
to Mark the end of that layer
[Applause]
I don't know I'm not loving it
I think it needs to scale up because the
Rings when they are repeating themselves
come at us so what I did is I selected
all the keys
right click either it doesn't matter
what key you select but if you select
it doesn't matter what key you right
click on if you have all the keys
selected I could right click here I
could right click here keyframe
assistant time reverse keyframes
so now it's going to pop on
actually it's not going to pop on it's
just going to scale right up
[Music]
[Applause]
so maybe it scales up let's see here
I think it should pop on here
and it should already be partially
scaled up so I'll just set a keyframe
here delete this keyframe
that's more interesting
[Applause]
but it needs to be quicker so we'll do
an ease in
and maybe we'll try that one 100 percent
influence thing here
[Music]
[Applause]
so that's more interesting
let's play it back
[Applause]
so when it disappears suddenly it feels
a little off to me because it's there
it's gone and there's another ring
already there right so maybe it should
disappear a frame earlier here
actually here
so that we see there's an empty circle
and then that pops on so let's try that
[Applause]
nope I don't like that I'm gonna Apple
command Z I always call it Apple Z
and I'm gonna try
[Music]
maybe we could try a transition I didn't
try this on the other version but we
could go to Just transition and we could
try uh let's see here what's a good one
radio wipe very simple transition
so maybe it uh
over the course of let's say one two
three
four
[Music]
five six I don't know we can go all the
way actually to here
maybe we just have transition go from
zero
two hundred
actually I did use this transition on
the last one
[Music]
[Applause]
so as it's transitioning maybe it just
starts scaling back down again
so maybe that
keyframe maybe that eases out let's try
this
[Applause]
I like it it's a little too quick though
like it's almost too much for my eye to
take in
hmm
maybe I could make it uh
semi-transparent let's try that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
I'm just gonna leave like this for now a
lot of times what I'll do is I'll just
experiment experience experiment take a
break let my eyes rest come back to it
or I'll continue moving forward as long
as I get it roughed in and there's
something interesting there I can always
come back and tweak and adjust and make
it better so that's what I'm going to do
I'm going to leave this where it's at
move forward and keep going
[Applause]
so on this part of the the track
I believe is around here let's just go
back to the original
yeah this is when I started traveling
through the tunnel which I thought was
really interesting uh just giving it so
all of a sudden some real 3D depth so
maybe we do something along those lines
here it's
[Applause]
oh
you know what I want to see something
here
[Music]
[Applause]
so right when everything pops
maybe it'd be interesting to see like a
like a radial array of uh circles maybe
that could be something interesting that
I didn't try before
so let's just go here and make a new
shape layer
double click on that
ellipse
and we'll make this guy a fairly small
well let's do 150.
and 150 150.
and let's go to repeater
foreign
ER
[Music]
and to this repeater let's work with the
rotation
foreign
let's add one more repeater here
we'll zero out the position on this one
as well
and we'll mess with the rotation again
it's really crazy
so maybe on this first one we'll do 45
degrees
and this next one will do
well that's interesting
it's one
two
three
okay
okay so it'd be interesting if we could
get these guys to like explode or
something like that like maybe explode
out
so I don't know what the best way to do
that is
um but what I would do in a situation
like this is just start experimenting
right
so
maybe the scale
okay so that's really cool
that could be a transition right there
so
I don't know maybe if we started with
that Center guy there
this is on the repeater
just enter transform under the repeater
bring this guy down to
13 and then a repeater one
I set a keyframe for this guy
yeah see that's really strange
well maybe that might not work for that
I could set a position keyframe though
and a scale keyframe it's like 14
percent
total experimentation here
but if I scale this up to let's say 100
25
and then this guy is 100
and this guy's a hundred
let's see what this looks like
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so to make that more interesting let's
ease in and these will definitely just
pull this puppy out
[Music]
foreign
so moving forward just a few frames
finding that snare
ends there
and then maybe at this point maybe it
just flies at us
like I did in that little
experimentation thing so like it's like
boom like that
let me undo that and just see what this
one does
oops I'll do that one
I don't know see what these do
[Music]
looks like I need to scale these guys up
too
[Music]
I don't know let's back up and look at
this
foreign
[Applause]
I
do like the scale when it comes in but
when it scales past the screen in my
test there it looked interesting but it
just doesn't work for for what I want to
do so maybe we could rotate it right
let's try a rotation
so this will ease out and then we'll
rotate it let's say I don't know maybe
one full rotation
but that needs to happen you know over a
little bit more time we don't want to
rotate too fast
so let's just set B
[Music]
so maybe it needs to rotate when it
comes on
that's obviously way too much of
rotation
so maybe 90 degrees
[Music]
and then overall the layers is too big
for me so maybe something like this
[Music]
let's back it up and see what it looks
like
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
something to happen with the snare and I
you know the more I look at this the
less I like all of these circles on the
screen at the same time so I want to get
rid of them pretty quickly
so I think
I'll just maybe try and scale them
really fast
up and
there's our transition
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's that's better
still feels a little lacking right in
here
so and you I should have mentioned
beginning this uh training series you
are going to get tired of hearing the
song over and over and over again but
this is how we get great timings
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
so there's a couple there's a like a Dun
Dun at the end that we're missing that I
feel like something should happen there
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah like right in here
and I'll do command a u to see if
there's any keyframes
and this stuff is starting to happen but
it's not happening quick enough
foreign
so maybe I'll select all these keyframes
and just drag them forward
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's always great in timings for motion
design to overlap
uh motion right so it's always it's more
it's more interesting if let's say
something's scaling up
and then it stops and it rotates well
that's kind of boring but if it's
scaling up and at the same time it's
doing a slight rotation and then maybe
that rotation continues on after the
scales hit 100 and then it moves on to
something else but a little bit of
overlapping motion uh really really
helps
[Applause]
so something's got to happen here
and I feel like it needs to be something
kind of elegant because of those strings
we hear
[Music]
I don't know what it is though so maybe
it's just an outlined Circle that comes
around this that could be you know
interesting
so I will just create another new shape
well
let's not do that let's just duplicate
the first layer bring it above
have it come in
right in there
and it's just going to scale up
very simply
and it's just going to be a small stroke
like a nice thin stroke
something like
that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so maybe it starts about right here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so it's going to contain all of these
elements
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
and what I'm seeing here I don't like is
like this stroke these
spheres are getting out the circles are
getting outside the stroke which I don't
want to happen
so I'm just gonna drag this influence
way up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and to make this a little bit more
interesting maybe we go into this layer
and we take off the repeater because we
do not need the repeater
that was just from the previous layer
and under add maybe we do a trim path
okay and let me show you what this can
do
so if I drag the 100 end
over in here so let's say we want a line
that's maybe that long
all I have to do is animate this offset
and it'll
move right around these guys just like
that
which would be really cool to see so
we'll start it
so it's going to complement the motion
of these guys coming out because they
rotate
this way right they rotate clockwise
and this line that's a circle around it
will also rotate clockwise as a
complementary uh secondary animation
just like that
go 360.
and we'll also use this one in and we're
going to make this well let's just
[Music]
[Applause]
so as it hits this ending point here I
want it to go away the easiest way to do
that is just to keyframe the end
so it's down to zero
and this is
all trial right here
maybe something like that
let's try this
cool I think this could uh benefit from
a second one of these maybe over in here
so we could duplicate this layer and
offset everything so there's one over
there or we could also try a repeater I
don't know if this will work or not
and instead of the position
being offset
zero that out maybe it's the rotation
that's offset
aha so it actually makes multiple ones
because we have it set to three so if we
set it to two
and we offset
by 180 degrees now there's two
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
so me getting nitpicky now I see this
come to a rest
I want these guys to do something right
here before they explode towards the
camera
what do they do
maybe they do something with
um
their
fill
maybe they do some of their fill but I
am going to apply an effect that
colorizes everything so maybe they just
do like another rotation
right so they've come to a stop here
and maybe they just spin real fast
Maybe 180.
they come real fast into that one and
they explode out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no I don't like that
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah that's not too bad I don't mind
that at all
so now let's just take a quick look at
this what we've got
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
not too bad so what I did next to give
it a more interesting look because I'm
not going to build this entire thing out
I mean I'm giving you guys uh this
project so you guys can really dissect
what I did uh this is just more to teach
you guys how to go about thinking about
this how to think about timings with
simple shapes right you could have
circles you could have squares
rectangles triangles whatever even an
abstract shape
you can make shapes look really
interesting
using very simple motion
repetition
[Music]
color
so that's what we're looking at today
and now let's talk about
how I colorize these
so what I did is I went into my effects
and under Sapphire render there's one
called gradient multi okay
and I believe I kept these colors all
the same just red green and blue RGB
but what I did was I applied some simple
Expressions to these guys to make them
that much more interesting
so what I did was you can see here
there's 0.1 XY on for each of these
right and that's how the color moves
around
so all I have to do is option click on
the point
and type my simple wiggle expression
wiggle parentheses and this was all
experimentation so I found that 7 was a
good speed and anywhere from 500 to 2000
was a good amplitude and that means how
much it's moving so if we did 7 1000 in
parentheses enter on your keyboard not
return enter if you have a numeric
keyboard or click outside the expression
you're going to see
this move so let me just turn off these
layers and I'll add a new background
there so we can see the colors
call this background
drag it to the background so here's our
colors right
I'll turn off the music
so you can see here that the first color
is moving so it's moving
at a speed of seven times per second
add an amplitude of a thousand pixels
right so it's kind of like jumping
around so what I did then is I went back
into the effect I option clicked on
point number two
and copy the expression of that point
number three copy the expression into
that so
easy way to do that is just you you on
your keyboard really quickly will open
up Expressions select
command C
I will hit
option 1.2
command V
enter now I've got two of them moving
go up to 0.3
option
paste
I got all four of them moving I think
what else I did is I turned up the
softness because you can see there's
some lines here these will be you know
hidden more once they're over these
circles
but if you increase the softness a bit
I don't want that
foreign
if I turn the softness way down you're
going to see these lines here
and back up
yeah that works
turn these circles back on
and I believe I set this grad only to
multiply
yeah there we go so if I preview this
you can see all of a sudden now these
white lines these white circles are
you know that much more interesting to
look at it reminded me of like a was the
colors from a CD is what I immediately
thought of and then kind of like this
party atmosphere uh like this the
circles are having a great time right
kind of like Guns and Roses who doesn't
love Guns and Roses right
they know how to party
so yeah so that's pretty cool there's a
few things about this that are bugging
me like when it goes full screen here I
don't love
these hot points here which I'm not real
sure why I'm seeing those hot points I
didn't notice those in the previous
version
maybe that's why I'll leave it at one
yeah that looks better already
so uh to this adjustment layer applied
some glow
but what I did is I turned the threshold
all the way down
actually let's let's turn it up just
slightly on the first version turned it
all the way down
I just wanted this to be very you know
kind of subtle
so a glow width of 92
[Music]
turn it to full
[Music]
that's a little too bright
so that's why I turned the threshold
down to 0.2 because when we get these
darker colors like this you don't see as
much of the glow if you turn it down
boom there it is
and it makes like these colors look that
much more pretty so this is with glow
without
yeah it looks really cool
okay so one thing I immediately see here
is you see this guy scales up
and then it sticks up here with these
weird glows I'll get rid of that
it's either
this guy or this guy it's that guy
yeah
all right so let's preview this and see
how it looks
[Applause]
[Applause]
very cool so of course we could go in we
could tweaks we tweak we could add more
things like
and here
which maybe I will
locate this
it's all about the little details
and for something like this it's so easy
just to repeat elements but slightly
adjust them
and you can get completely you know
different uh results when you do that
foreign
there he's gone
[Music]
yeah I mean even that works
might be cool just to repeat
three times and instead of going in and
maybe it goes out
like that that could be kind of cool
so we'll start at a hundred
pops on right there
and just kind of flies
like so like maybe like that
maybe like right there
so there I like it
they're not so much they're I do okay so
I like it there
I like it there
I don't love it there but I do like it
there
so let's try that
[Music]
yeah and it's so quick
[Music]
so just adding that one little layer
there made a difference in my opinion so
let's go back and check it out again
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
very cool I think as one final step I
added a little bit of noise but what I
did this time is I went to layer new
solid
and I called this noise
and I went to effect
noise and green
add noise
turn it up just slightly
and set it to was it screen or multiply
in the screen
so I turned it way down
10 there's 10 percent on that's off on
even a little bit less maybe eight
percent
off yeah very subtle but uh helps kind
of Polish It Off
so there you go there's our example of
circle shapes
I invite you to definitely dive in to
this original project it's much more
involved uh it's got a little bit of 3D
camera movement going on
uh very interesting both projects I
really enjoyed doing these these are a
little bit different for me I loved
adding all the colors and things like
that
to make a little bit different so leave
a comment let me know what you thought
I've also got an assessment at the end
of this to give this training series a
rating I'd like to get some rating
reviews from you guys and see what you
guys are liking what you're not liking
what kind of falls in the middle so I
can continue to build these training
videos forward for what matches what you
need to learn so
I hope you guys enjoyed this lesson I
absolutely did enjoy creating this was a
lot of fun
and uh yeah I'll see you guys real soon
see ya